للنتائج التي تظهر لحظه بلحظه حتى الان
هناك ولايات لم تحسن بعد قد تكون فعلا
حاسمه كما كانت التوقعات وتنجح كافه حزب
على الاخر ما هي هذه الولايات التي لم
تحسن بعد في هذه الاطلاله سنركز سنركز
عليها تماما ونشرح ما هي اهميه هذه
الولايات التي كانت تعتبر متارجحه واثبتت
فعلا بانها متارجحه وحاسمه ولايه مثل
ولايه جورجيا مع فرز 96% من الاصوات
لاحظوا النتيجه متقاربه جدا ايضا بين
رفايا الورنك الديمقراطي مع 49 فاصل
42% للمرشح الديمقراطي مقابل 48 فاصل 51
بالمئه لهرشل وبوكر المرشح الجمهوري الذي
ص نجمه خلال السنوات الماضيه ليكون مرشحا
حقيقيا وجديا في هذه الولايه في ولايه
جورجيا
96% من الاصوات تم فرزها الفارق دئيل
وبسيط جدا قد تقول هذه الولايه لاي من
المرشحين المرشح الديمقراطي رافالنك مع
49.42% ام هيرشيلد ووكر الجمهوري مع 48
فاصل
51% اربعه بالمئه فقط من الاصوات هي التي
ستقرر من سيفوز في هذه الولايه المهمه جدا
اذا فاز فيها الحزب الجمهوري كما كان
متوقعا فاذا سيكون على بعض مقعدين فقط
ليحقق او يحافظ على الاغلبيه التي كان
يمتلكها قبل هذه الانتخابات اذا هذه ولايه
مهمه هي ولايه جورجيا هناك ولايه ايضا
اخرى مهمه
ولاحظوا ايضا التقارب بالنتيجه ولايه
بنسلفانيا ولا هي مهمه جدا شهدت اذا
تذكرون في الانتخابات الماضيه لانتخابات
الرئاسيه بين بايضن وترامب شهدت جدلا
واسعا بسبب مقاله ترامب والمعسكر الجمهوري
بانه تم اااه سرقه الانتخابات في
بنسلفانيا بسبب ما تعرف بالاصوات المبكره
او التصويت بالبريد
83% من الاصوات تم فرزها جون فطرمان يتقدم
ب 49 فاصل 44% على مهنه اوس بثمانيه
واربعين فاصل
16% النتيجه متقاربه جدا وايضا هذه
الولايه قد تقول لاي من الطرفين يفصلها
فقط سبعه بالمئه لتحسن لامه للحزب
الديمقراطي اما للحزب الجمهوري وال
متقاربه جدا بين الحزين في ولايه
بنسلفانيا التي ايضا تعتبر مهمه جدا جدا
ماذا عن ويسكانسن وسكانسن ايضا ولايه مهمه
ايضا لاحظوا الفارق ضئيل اقل من واحد
بالمئه 49 فاصل ثلاثه
للمنديلارنس الديمقراطي في ولايه وسكانسن
في مقابل 50 فاصل سبعه بالمئه ليران
جونسون الجمهوري الذي يحاول الحفاظ على
هذه الولايه وسكنسن 10% فقط من الاصوات
تفصيلنا عن الحسن في هذه الولايه وممكن
ايضا ان تقول لاي من الطرفين لاي من
الحسبين وبالتالي ممكن ان تقلب المعادله
التي بدات تتشكل شيئا فشيئا في هذه
الانتخابات اذا هذا ما يتعلق بوسكنسن ماذا
عن مجلس الشي الان مجلس الشيوخ 47 للحزب
الديمقراطي يبتعد بثلاث اصوات فقط ثلاث
مقاعد ثلاثه مقاعد فقط يبتعد هنا الحزب
الديمقراطي ليحافظ على اغلبيته في مجلس
الشيوخ مقابل 46 للحزب الجمهوري اربعه
مقاعد او اربعه اصوات ستمنح الحزب
الجمهوري ربما الغلبه في هذا المجلس ولكن
على ما يبدو بان الامور تسير عكس ما كان
يشتهي الحسبه الجمهوري وهذا مقاله
لانسر جراهام قال انه يبدو لا نشهد موجه
حمراء بحسب تصريحاته تصريحاته لان
التوقعات كانت تقول بان الحزب الجمهوري
سيستطيع ان يحقق خرقا في مجلس الشيوخ وفي
مجلس النواب بطبيعه الحال اذا هذا هو مجلس
الشيوخ تابعوا معي الولايات على الصعيد
الولايات في مجلس الشيوخ 47
للحزب الديمقراطي 46 للحزب الجمهوري اهم
الولايات التي حصل عليها الحزب الجمهوري
فلوريدا مع ماركو روبيو كنتاكي مع راند
بول حصل ايضا على ايدي هون
حصل ايضا على كانسيس على اوكلاهوما على
اركن سوا وغيرها من الولايات الحمراء
بينما الحزب الجمهوري الحزب الديمقراطي
باللون الازرق حصل على ولايات في اقصى
الغرب على الساحل الغربي واشنطن
كاليفورنيا كلورادو وهي كانت متوقع بطبيعه
الحال انوي نيويورك ايضا كانت مهمه
بالنسبه لاتشاك ايه شومر استطاع ان يحصل
عليها اضافه الى بعض الولايات منها ماريلا
منها كونتيكا في هذه المنطقه ولكن نعود
ونركز لاحظ هذه الولايات باللون الاصفر
خاصه بانسلفانيا جورجيا اريزونا ونيفادا
لا تسال باللون الاصفر لم تحسم بعد وقد
تكون هي الحاسمه في هذه الانتخابات
النصفيه